first of all when did they ask you to
present at the uh
not long before someone must have
dropped out are you excited by that to
present at the oscars or do you not care
about that
yeah no i think it's an honor it's kind
of fun i had a documentary that was
nominated so i was really excited to be
there
is that the one you shot on your iphone
no that was a music video
yeah well how do you shoot who did you
shoot that for a band called edward
sharp and the magnetic zeros they
approach you
because they hear you're a good director
yeah they knew me and they knew i knew
their music and and i had said a couple
years ago i want to shoot a music video
and i said we could even shoot it on an
iphone
and then the iphone got like really
great it's pretty good the quality yeah
now you can shoot on 4k
it looks great and so we went for it it
turned out well when you say we
so this band approaches you they
obviously don't have a lot of money
right so
you have to figure out a way to shoot
this thing rather than get involved with
how expensive is it to shoot
an iphone video it's got to be very
cheap it's very cheap you know what we
did though is we put a lot of
lenses on it you know you take still
camera lenses i had an amazing dp a
woman named reed morano who's like the
coolest chick in the world
who pays for this the record company
well you know we
once we were shooting it on the iphone
then apple kind of stepped in to help us
make the production work because then
you know because they don't want to look
like jerks
they were like please don't make it look
bad right
is it possible to make a the video that
you saw in your head on an iphone
yeah absolutely and it looked good it
looks really good and i don't think
anyone
believes it was on an iphone i gotta
look that up i've seen guys shoot stuff
on gopro and stuff and it looks
unbelievable yeah and that movie
tangerine last year was on an iphone
that was the iphone 5. so
it's really come a long way do you film
the artist singing and can you sync up
everything
perfectly no kidding yeah it's there's
there's challenges but we had an amazing
crew what are the challenges
because it's just the technology the
technology is tricky you know
for one thing the phone is very light so
it's hard to to have a handheld shot
that's very that's stable
and the other thing is that you have to
kind of pull focus while you're shooting
at the same time you don't have a focus
puller next to you
and the exposure is a little bit
trickier so it is amazing are you one of
these people are you like a nun
that runs around with your iphone all
the time are you constantly taking
pictures of yourself and other people
are you are you are you chained to your
iphone
oh god i mean i i think i am in
too much i mean but i'm still the person
that refuses to accept that there's
wi-fi on airplanes
right like now people can reach you on
an airplane i just pretend i'm not aware
of that